okay uh now
how far did you get um if we try to work
out how much he
regularly has to invest and adjust that
right um
hopefully because we've been doing this
same question the same scenario so many
times
you'll see the pattern right i'm just
after a different value and in fact by
this point
you're like oh all of this stuff is very
easy to determine
okay so all i have to do to get a is
just cut it all over the other side of
the equation
right so you write something like this
50 000
multiplied by the denominator and
divided by
the numerator and what you get by the
way
what values you get give me the decimals
what amount did we get 1011 and
okay can you give me more decimals
six seven six seven six two three three
four
six three all right good now
uh to go up here to round up is again
the right thing to do
um actually i just say the amount
sorry 11 and 68. now the key to get here
is
we sort of got lucky on this because it
rounds up anyway right
but if it was um 0.671
right or 6701 or whatever right
the point is again if we go down just a
little bit okay
that cumulative effect it won't get us
to the 50 grand okay
so i hesitate to give rules of thumb
because rules of thumb will often
bite you back later if you forget what
they mean but generally speaking here
when you're getting an amount or a time
you're gonna have to go past it right
because if you go less you won't reach
the target
okay all right now uh so here we go
uh a thousand eleven now by the way does
that
does that sit with you does that gel
with you you're like
i only want to save four years and i
have to invest
every year a third as much again right
well that's the way compound interest
works okay so you can sort of see a
pattern here
now by this point you're probably
wondering okay
i'm getting the same kind of shape
happening again and again and again
can i generalize this that's something
we usually do right so
let's just have a go generalizing and
see what happens um
generalizing what have we got here
meaning you know take out all the
concrete details about how much the
actual interest rate is or how long
you're doing it or whatever
let's go with these products here okay
well
the total value will be equal to there's
the amount that we're regularly
investing
we see it there at the front and then
what i'll multiply by
okay what did what do these numbers
signify
let's just for the sake of not having
fractions in our
general equation this r this interest
rate okay let's actually call it rather
than saying
it's eight let's call it point zero
eight or eight percent
that's what the percent means right
divided by a hundred so
1.08 is uh one
plus your interest rate right that's
where it appears that's where it comes
from
you can tell me that and then in the
brackets here
you've got that same value to the power
of
the time the duration right here's my n
what do i divide by just the rate on its
own
is that okay all right now i'll just do
one more thing because i can see i've
gone r here and are there
i can sort of make this a little bit
tidier i can do this
make that a one over r and that's a one
and here we go this stuff in brackets
okay now let's have a think about this
first thing
why is it that we can well what's
valuable about this the first thing i
think which is helpful
is that when you look at this equation
you can see the four pieces that make
it up right and so it sort of simplifies
the process of trying to work out
if i've got excuse me if i'm trying to
work out this or i've got this or
whatever
it's quite straightforward this is so
like quadratic formula right
it's the same kind of approaching it can
be quite mindless right
um so that's nice it sort of takes out
the steps of us
creating the gp right but what are the
problems with it
here we go number one it masks the fact
when you look at it right
it masks the fact that this came from a
gp and that's a problem for us right
because what it means is if we don't
know where it came from
you know there's no place i can put in
here like johnny broke his leg
in the 10th year of his superannuation
so he couldn't put 750 anymore he could
only put in
250 or something like that you know
because he was you know reduced to
i don't know gold mining for something
like that right
um so you you can't adjust it um
secondly
you know uh when you when you're using
this form if you make an
error it's like where did it come from i
don't know okay um so
you've got the um the problem off if
there's an adjustment to the kind of
scenario
if it's not nice and neat like this and
come on you change loose it's not going
to be nice and neat right
um it can't be adjusted right there's no
there's no
johnny brook who's led in premium rule
okay that you can adjust
so you're going to have to build the gp
from scratch almost every time
even when you don't it's a good idea to
do it because that way you know if it's
a format question
i can give the other three marks
somewhere as opposed to just the final
note
okay now the last thing that is actually
helpful about this
is it draws out a problem we've got this
table here we've got this one last row
okay so what might you imagine in the
last scenario would be
he's like i i've only got 50 grand
oh i want to get 50 grand sorry i've
only got 20 years to play with
okay but i can't i can't put that in
every year that's crazy i've got needs
all right so i can only put in 750
regularly okay so he goes to the um
superannuation fund and he lays it on
table he's like look
this is the interest rate that i need
okay so i'm trying to work out
what r is okay now
when you look at it i'm just going to
spare you the trouble
because if you have a look at this thing
here right let's just let's just fill it
up shall we
put a 50 000 in here
you put your 750 in here
and you're putting your time your 20
years
here now can anyone see the glaring
problem
when we were trying to work out time we
had we did have a problem which is that
the pronun we were interested in the
variable the unknown was in the power
but we had logs so we could deal with
that right
but here we're in trouble right
because uh well you've got two problems
number one unlike
the other things right t a and there's
only one of those
right i mean in terms of in the equation
okay so when you're trying to
find the subject or rearrange the
subject you just have one
target to go after here you're like
which r do i go after
now when you've got more than one
prenumeral appearance
right or you've got the same one
appearing twice usually you expand out
right and then you sort of refactorize
and make it work
but of course the problem with that is
this guy right
how do you expand that out well you can
expand it out but what you get in the
end is
rather not helpful because it's going to
be
this is r to the power of 20 right so
you thought your polynomials to the
power of like four or five were bad this
is a whole new world
so therefore there are two ways to solve
this kind of question
uh the first way is by guessing
and that actually has appeared in some
hsc
questions before you can actually guess
and check this just like you can guess
inject the time
there's another way of doing it it's a
weird thing
it's a method for finding um the roots
of equations where the powers are really
stupid basically okay i could change the
200 and this method
newton's method um is a way of it's it's
sort of like
an elaborate guided guess and check
that's basically what it is okay
now um when do we actually learn this
thing um get this we learn it all the
way after
your trials so term three next year when
you finish your trial of the big exam
then we learn this guy so guess what
we're not going to do this question
at least not now anyway okay i can show
you the guess and check afterwards but
here's the important thing
these three questions here these ones
you'll really have to fish
okay um occasionally this guy will come
up as like a question
10 of an hsc but we'll get to that when
we get to newton's bet
okay but that's why i'm just explaining
we're like wait we've got four things
why are we only doing three of them